hey everyone it's Mike BOS and welcome
to the order flows market analysis for
Wednesday July 26 2017 so there were no
surprises in the July FC statement rates
were held steady and no further hints
were given at the start sorry for the
start of tapering and still expected at
either September or December meetings so
you know the lack of inflation however
is giving some concern though other
economic assessments from the fomc held
steady and are positive doll ended up
today positive about a half a percent um
S&P is also uh didn't really you know it
was very uneventful trading as far as uh
equities went but you know there were
still some very interesting things in
the order flow which I I'll talk about
here in a second so you know first
before we get started brief disclaimer
this presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only it should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures training contains St or risk and
is not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's Financial Security or
lifestyle only risk Capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
now the tools I use in this presentation
are the tools I developed the orderflows
trader which is a volume footprint chart
and the Delta scalper which is a tool
that reads uh the delta in the order
flow so let's uh let's take a look at
some of these markets
today talk about snps and you know S&S
were kind of mixed on the day I said you
know dowo finished marginally higher but
S&P is pretty much Hold Steady um at the
close now you know 8:30 when the cash
open we popped up here made a new high
we had a Divergence no ratio um we came
off and we just sort of hung around the
opening price now when the markets
directionless it's just going to hang
around the opening price and you know
just because you don't have one one
particular type of Trader either daytime
frame Trader long-term Trader uh in
control of the market and you know
reason being we had fomc coming out uh
today and generally you know on the lead
up into the uh fomc announcement it
really quiets down and you can see here
we we're trading in a Range um you know
basically after the cash opened we're
trading uh basically 78 down to 74
opening price was 75 and a quarter and
so you know we're just rotating around
there rotating around um
later in the day just for the cash close
we made a new low barely made a new low
by a few ticks now it was interesting
because you know this blue line that I
have drawn in here is what I consider
yesterday's volume value area low based
off the uh volume profile from the day
before
um where am I wrong day here it is okay
so you know yesterday I drew this line
in here at 74 because you know we're
spending we're we're coming down towards
74 value area high for me was probably
around here up at 78 so that's why I
have this La this line drawn here and I
thought if we could really get below 74
maybe we could make a run at 72 which is
the low at that time and you can see how
we ended up the volume profile like this
but you know coming into the morning you
know around
n it volume it was very very thin volume
here um you know just a few
you know a few hundred if that even and
like I said you know there was there was
no no uh support really to to come in
and what happens is we finally you know
we got through it once and we rallied
right back up this was obviously right
uh 1:00 here but then later in the day
you know once things settled down going
into the close uh we broke we got the
stack [__] balance here came down hit the
low here at 72 made a new low at 712
down here what do you got you got a
ratio and Divergence I talk about these
things every day until I'm like blue in
the face people are probably sick yeah
whatever Vos you're crazy but then what
what happens we rally off that into the
evening session here at 8:00 where we
are you know a move from 74 back up to
77 so you know while there really wasn't
much
early it happened late and it happened
closer to the close again I'm not a big
fan of trading going into the close
going into the cash close but you know
you got this nice little setup here um
this is something I talk about in Daily
ratios and
Divergence okay so the next Market uh
I'll talk about also is is a ratio
Divergence it's the Euro stocks and
again you know I I just showed you a
ratio and Divergence sell sorry a buy
this one's a sell um this was at 445
we're ring up here make a new high we
got a ratio and a Divergence and what
happens the market sells off Euro stocks
from uh you know the 3490 area down to
4 75
76 so nice 15 uh tick move in in the
Euro stocks which you know 15 ticks in
the Euros stocks is is is a nice move
it's tend to be a slower moving contract
okay the next market I'll talk about is
Japanese y now this is a 15-minute chart
again you don't really see me talking
much about 15-minute charts in order
flow personally I think it's a little
bit uh long but still you know you're
still looking for the same things here
you got the Delta scalper given a buy
you got a nice move up to new highs I
had to scrunch this so it's a little bit
hard to read the numbers but again I'm
really not concerned with the individual
numbers inside the bar in most cases I
mean there are times that I am but again
you I'm looking for the same things I'm
looking for divergences and ratios here
you have a Divergence no ratio here you
got a Divergence and a ratio in the next
bar and you know what happens we go from
uh 8961 we make a nice move down down
down down down down to new lows you know
893s even lower here then you know
obviously we we start to Rally back but
we had a big uh big rally nothing here
in the order flow um you know obviously
1:00 we had that big bar but you know
again I'm I'm still looking at the same
things you know whether it's a you know
a a eight range chart whether it's a
four range chart 10 range chart 15minute
chart you know I'm still looking for the
same things ratio and
Divergence okay so next I'll talk about
is the euro currency on an 8 chart and I
talk about is point of control in this
bar point of control right on the
extreme and again you know a couple
weeks ago I did a webiner presentation
and then this is the setup that I gave
you know look for these red bars with
point of control right on the extreme
also you have a bearish
ratio and what happens is the market
makes this this beautiful sell off
straight down um this is a like like the
textbook example boom you got a new
high most volumes traded in the bar
right on the high it happens to be the
high of the day price action the bar
changes you know we close lower you know
we we you got positive Delta 300 we
should have a green bar we should be
trading higher but what's happening is
Everything's changed in that bar why
because we ran into some stopping volume
up there um you know it's like you know
the market is rallying rallying rallying
everyone's getting excited hey we're
going higher boom there's a big seller
there stopping this move higher and and
it just Falls over so you know this is a
textbook example for the cell and I'm
going to show you literally the the
opposite the textbook example for a buy
if I could find the chart here it was in
the Aussie dollar just give me a second
here here it
is okay now it happened early in the
session happened about 1: in the morning
but boom there it is this is a textbook
example for the buy point of control
right on the bottom happens to be the
low of the day it's a green candle point
of control right on the bottom U you got
also a ratio bounds low indicating
stopping volume here and what happens we
Rally from this low literally up not up
to the highs I think later we took out
the
highs you know much much later but still
um you know at 1: in the morning you
know this is something you could have
bought and you know you take very little
if if any heat you know initially maybe
if you got in early in this bar you
bought here you took a little bit of
heat down to here um but then after that
it was it was nothing it just free
sailing all morning and into the
afternoon
okay so this is NASDAQ um same thing
point of control right on the top now
you tend to get these point of control
extremes more in some of these contracts
such as uh NASDAQ mini da than you do in
the currencies yeah you get them in the
currencies and you know even other
contracts but a little bit less frequent
I I find it tends to occur a little bit
more frequently in contracts like uh as
you know some of these the smaller
indices
and commodities so here's perfect
example boom you hit it you come off a
little bit it's not the greatest sell
off I mean it's not like you sold off
from your high to your low but again you
know you're looking for you know
anything that's going to give you you
know a move and you know you get that
there eventually it does fall over but
you know honestly you know you get short
here and it just does this Meandering
thing it'd probably be getting out
somewhere down here or down here before
it starts ring back up yeah I don't I'm
not going to say you're going to hold it
uh you know all morning like this
especially when it's just sort of up and
down up and down but again you know I I
did that presentation uh a couple weeks
ago and you know that that's what I
talked about so again you know it it's
not some you know hidden Holy Grail
secret do they always work no there's
sometimes where the next bar comes down
and then the third bar just ralles right
up to you um but you know what the
market is telling you is that there's
there's stopping volume up here you know
people are getting excited we're trying
to break it out but boom it just runs
into a big um some Supply up here that's
you know basically halts the move for
now you know whether it it remains to be
seen if it's going to be all day or for
the short term but really what you're
looking for right when you're in trading
intraday is you're looking for these you
know
short-term movements you know something
to stop this move and once you realize
that hey there's something stopping this
move yeah then you could take your trade
right you're only risking this up to
here if we get past this level up here
with the point of control is you know
the whole reason for the trade is over
and you're you should be getting out
immediately you know you're not getting
out another five ticks higher no you're
just getting out right above that area
so you know where your risk
is okay so real quick I'll talk about
crude oil um not a whole lot in the
order flow but you know with the
indicator of Delta scalper I mean I
could sit here and I I could talk about
know the Delta but you know it's just
easier for me to talk about the Delta
scalper um showing you
where you had the Delta expansion or
contraction so you know up here 2: in
the morning you're getting some new
highs put in here boom boom Divergence
that failed you got another Divergence
that failed here but then right after
that boom you got Delta scalper kicking
off so it's telling you there's a shift
in supply and demand we went from a
demand driven Market higher here to a
supply driven Market there's a lot of
Supply coming into the market here and
what happens is you sell off from you
know 4840 area down to new lows 48 uh
you know 4820 and then you just
eventually make new lows boom boom boom
you know not a whole lot here in the
order flow I mean I can make some
arguments in here but you know that
that's a bit Advanced for people um
obviously 9:30 we had the inventory
numbers come out that's why you sort of
see this thin volume up in here now we
did uh Rally from your lows all the way
back up to your highs you know you got a
where's your high up here right up here
right off the high
now you know very strong buying coming
up here then gets weak up here you have
a ratio here then Delta scalper again so
you know very strong demand I mean look
at these positive Deltas 1100 600 1200
1,600 but Delta scalper is telling you
there's a shift there's a change here in
supply and demand you're going You're
there's a strong this is what a demand
driven Market looks like but now it's
telling you early that hey you know what
demand is dried up Supply is coming into
the market and what happens we make a
move from you know basically this 4870
call it 75 area all the way down down
down pretty much a straight line not
straight line but you know straight
angle 45° angle down down down to new
lows you know see imagine that you're
going from your
high up here just off your high this is
your high
4887 Delta scalper telling you this
early right off the high in real time
you know it's not like coming off down
here or anything like that it's it's
right here a second bar off the high so
you know anywhere in here you going be
getting short very easily this is you
know between 4870 and
4880 all the the way down where do you
got where do you got any buying coming
in do you see any buying coming in down
here no you see some buying coming here
you know you got a green bar you got a
positive Delta that's it you know a
little bit of pop up and then you know
all selling some more
selling all the way down down down stack
selling bance it's just picking up it's
rolling downhill already down into new
lows you know for so from you know 4870
what are you trading down you finally
sort of Bot them out down here honestly
i' I'd be looking you know somewhere
down here cuz you got this imbalance
another
imbalance down in here really gets a bit
iffy cuz it's it's just bouncing around
pretty fast this is 952 and you know 3
seconds 11 seconds so you know this is
It's 70c move pretty quick you it does
recover back up here so who knows you
know
um maybe by the time you get out it's
trading 4810 so you know okay so instead
of a 70 Cent move it's 60 Cent move got
another Delta scalper here this one
starts working out but it turns around
on you and rallies up and stops you out
but you know that's okay right that's
okay if you're getting short here you're
getting stopped out up here getting
short at you know
4822 but you're getting stopped out at
you know 4832 that's okay that's only 10
ticks right but you just had this
monster trade of 60 or 70 ticks right
behind you you know uh sorry right right
before that
trade so again again you know a little
bit later Delta scalper again another
nice little sell
here boom boom boom boom boom boom again
you know by if you're sitting in a
position at
1250 you know in this bar and it's in
your favor and you know you got the fomc
announcement coming out you really
should be considering getting out but uh
again that's that's up to that's up to
you the trader um and you know so that
was it for the the crude oil so again
you know I I talk about these same
things every day um Delta scoper I talk
about ratios in Divergence and you know
point of controls at the extreme these
are you know things that occur daily in
the markets and I talk about the same
markets every day over and over um crude
oil e minis today I showed you Euro
stock today I showed you a 15minute
chart on Japanese Yen but it's the same
concept same same things you're looking
for in different markets so can it work
in other markets yeah can it work on
longer term time frames I mean look I
mean I could show you also um let me see
if I got the
chart handy
here it's uh it's in the eurocurrency
okay again
another uh where is it
here again you know I'm not a big fan of
trading 15minute charts but you know the
same thing that I I look on look at you
know on on a on a f minute chart or say
uh you know an eight range chart or a 10
range chart or whatever type of chart
I'm looking at is also you know on a
15-minute chart boom here you got
eurocurrency 15-minute chart ratio and
Divergence now do you get these every
day on 15-minute charts no you don't um
you know I I find it works better when
when Market's a bit more volatile but um
you know on 15-minute charts I like
movement okay so problem I I say a
problem you know only reason I'm not a
big fan of minute based charts is like
this 15-minute chart look at this bar
it's uh
166 sorry uh 116 80 up to uh you know 88
but the bar before it is just you know
how many ticks it's very small you know
I like my bar I like the bars to move
based on on price rather than based on
time but that's just that's me you know
and I know some people they they have to
trade on 15minute charts for whatever
reason you know they're stuck to them
they're married to them but again you
know you're getting this move from here
11670 all the way down to you know in
here somewhere you know here you get a
bullish sign
but yeah you're getting some moves right
the same things you're looking at exact
same things whether it's a minute based
chart a range based chart
um you know a tick
chart so anyway uh you know thanks for
watching this video um to learn more
about order flows visit my website order
flows.com or visit Delta scalper to
learn more about the Delta scalper I'll
be making a video a little bit later on
on the Delta scalper how it performed
today so thanks everyone
bye-bye